SPEED
YOUGOT THE RETREATS TO CENTER R!
INTO THE GLOVE AND HE WILL HOLD.
NOW BACK UP HIG
NATIONWIDE ARENA.
WHAT A START TO THIS ONE. THE P.
TURNS IT OVER TO
KURALY
YOU KNOW, IT LOOK LIKE IT HIT.
>> Jeff: WEB SIT AROUND
STUMBLES.
THERE IS A
YOU KNOW CROSBY IS GOING TO GET
QUICKLY TES.HAND.
SO JEFF GOES IF I GO THIS WAY, I
KNOW HE'S GOING TO GET OUT IN L,
SWITCH IT OFF INTO THE 5-ON-5.
THEY ARE PURSUING BELOW THE NET
AS THEY TRY TOGGLES THE REBOUNDS
UPPEARS TO BE ALL RIGHT LIKE HE
SHOT OUT OF A TO BE A PUCKS, C .
EVER SO CALM.
THE GLOVE KINDS OF TRAFFIC IN FF
THME REALLY
TIGHT PASSING SHOT THERE, T T AT
ROSLOVIC.
ROSLOVIC MAKES THE PLAY.
BUT YOU CA GETS HIGH.
AND AS HE DOES, HE GETS OUTSIDE
NO QUESTION THERE WAS CONTA
TO ME, THAT CONTACT KNOCKS OUT
OF HIS GLOVE AND THAT ALLOWS
CROSBY TO SC